But if you become the president of Zimbabwe,
and you say, "You know, I really like this job.
I think I'd like to stay in it forever." (Laughter)
Well, you just can.
You decide you want to print money.
You call the central bank governor and you say,
"Please double the money supply."
He'll say, "Okay, yes, sir,
is there anything else I can do for you?"
This is the power that African leaders have,
and this is why they make the most difference
on the continent.
The good news is that
the quality of leadership in Africa has been improving.
We've had three generations of leaders, in my mind.
Generation one are those who appeared
in the '50s and '60s.
These are people like Kwame Nkrumah of Ghana
and Julius Nyerere of Tanzania.
The legacy they left is that they brought independence to Africa.
They freed us from colonialism,
and let's give them credit for that.
They were followed by generation two.
These are people that brought nothing
but havoc to Africa.
Think warfare, corruption, human rights abuses.
This is the stereotype of the typical African leader
that we typically think of:
Mobutu Sese Seko from Zaire,
Sani Abacha from Nigeria.
The good news is that most of these leaders have moved on,
and they were replaced by generation three.
These are people like the late Nelson Mandela
and most of the leaders that we see in Africa today,
like Paul Kagame and so forth.
Now these leaders are by no means perfect,
but the one thing they have done is that they have
cleaned up much of the mess of generation two.
They've stopped the fighting,
and I call them the stabilizer generation.
They're much more accountable to their people,
they've improved macroeconomic policies,
and we are seeing for the first time
Africa's growing, and in fact it's the second fastest
growing economic region in the world.
So these leaders are by no means perfect,
but they are by and large
the best leaders we've seen in the last 50 years.
So where to from here?
I believe that the next generation
to come after this, generation four,
has a unique opportunity
to transform the continent.
Specifically, they can do two things
that previous generations have not done.
The first thing they need to do
is they need to create prosperity for the continent.
Why is prosperity so important?
Because none of the previous generations
have been able to tackle this issue of poverty.
Africa today
has the fastest growing population in the world,
but also is the poorest.
By 2030, Africa will have a larger workforce than China,
and by 2050, it will have the largest workforce in the world.
One billion people will need jobs in Africa,
so if we don't grow our economies fast enough,
we're sitting on a ticking time bomb,
not just for Africa but for the entire world.
Let me show you an example
of one person who is living up to this legacy
of creating prosperity: Laetitia.
Laetitia's a young woman from Kenya
who at the age of 13 had to drop out of school
because her family couldn't afford to pay fees for her.
So she started her own business rearing rabbits,
which happen to be a delicacy in this part of Kenya
that she's from.
This business did so well that within a year,
she was employing 15 women
and was able to generate enough income
that she was able to send herself to school,
and through these women
fund another 65 children to go to school.
The profits that she generated,
she used that to build a school,
and today she educates
400 children in her community.
And she's just turned 18.
(Applause)
Another example is Erick Rajaonary.
Erick comes from the island of Madagascar.
Now, Erick realized that agriculture
would be the key to creating jobs
in the rural areas of Madagascar,
but he also realized that fertilizer was a very
expensive input for most farmers in Madagascar.
Madagascar has these very special bats
that produce these droppings
that are very high in nutrients.
In 2006, Erick quit his job as a chartered accountant
and started a company to manufacture
fertilizer from the bat droppings.
Today, Erick has built a business
that generates several million dollars of revenue,
and he employs 70 people full time
and another 800 people during the season
when the bats drop their droppings the most.
Now, what I like about this story
is that it shows that opportunities to create prosperity
can be found almost anywhere.
Erick is known as the Batman.
(Laughter)
And who would have thought that you would have
been able to build a multimillion-dollar business
employing so many people just from bat poo?
The second thing that this generation needs to do
is to create our institutions.
They need to build these institutions such that we
are never held to ransom again
by a few individuals like Robert Mugabe.
Now, all of this sounds great,
but where are we going to get this generation four from?
Do we just sit and hope that they emerge
by chance, or that God gives them to us?
No, I don't think so.
It's too important an issue for us to leave it to chance.
I believe that we need to create African institutions,
home-grown, that will identify and develop
these leaders in a systematic, practical way.
We've been doing this for the last 10 years
through the African Leadership Academy.
Laetitia is one of our young leaders.
Today, we have 700 of them that are being groomed
for the African continent,
and over the next 50 years,
we expect to create 6,000 of them.
But one thing has been troubling me.
We would get about 4,000 applications a year
for 100 young leaders that we could take
into this academy,
and so I saw the tremendous hunger that existed
for this leadership training that we're offering.
But we couldn't satisfy it.
So today, I'm announcing for the first time in public
an extension to this vision for the African Leadership Academy.
We're building 25 brand new universities in Africa
that are going to cultivate this next generation
of African leaders.
Each campus will have 10,000 leaders at a time
so we'll be educating and developing
250,000 leaders at any given time.
(Applause)
Over the next 50 years, this institution
will create three million transformative leaders
for the continent.
My hope is that half of them
will become the entrepreneurs that we need,
who will create these jobs that we need,
and the other half
will go into government
and the nonprofit sector,
and they will build the institutions that we need.
But they won't just learn academics.
They will also learn how to become leaders,
and they will develop their skills as entrepreneurs.
So think of this as Africa's Ivy League,
but instead of getting admitted because of your SAT scores
or because of how much money you have
or which family you come from,
the main criteria for getting into this university
will be what is the potential that you have
for transforming Africa?
But what we're doing is just one group of institutions.
We cannot transform Africa by ourselves.
My hope
is that many, many other home-grown
African institutions will blossom,
and these institutions will all come together
with a common vision of developing
this next generation of African leaders,
generation four,
and they will teach them this common message:
create jobs, build our institutions.
Nelson Mandela once said,
"Every now and then,
a generation is called upon to be great.
You can be that great generation."
I believe that if we carefully identify and cultivate
the next generation of African leaders,
then this generation four that is coming up
will be the greatest generation that Africa
and indeed the entire world has ever seen.
Thank you.
(Applause)